merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carrère je voudrais vous
remercier de cette caisse de me poser
cette question qui pose la question de
l'équilibre entre un groupe pastoralisme
et nous en particulier j'étais comme
vous le savez en fin de semaine dans le
Doubs puis dans sa voix enfin dans les
deux savoirs pour évoquer en particulier
cette question qui est très prégnante
nul ne peut évoquer cette question et
vous avez raison de rappeler sans
souligner quand on est auprès des
éleveurs j'ai été rencontré un éleveur
qui venait d'être prédaté le sentiment
de détresse le sentiment d'impuissance
et le sentiment d'incompréhension qu'ils
ont de la prédation et de la menace que
ça fait peser sur deux sur eux deuxième
élément rappelez quand même que le
pastoralisme vous l'avez dit pour des
questions touristiques mais c'est un
modèle qui est un modèle exemplaire
aussi en termes de biodiversité il y a
besoin de préserver la biodiversité du
lot mais il y a aussi besoin de
préserver les autres formes de
biodiversité qui sont garanties par les
activités de pastoralisme et
d'agriculture extensive alors comment
nous pouvons agir d'abord le président
de la République l'a rappelé dans votre
département cet été l'idée c'est qu'au
niveau européen nous travaillons sur le
statut de l'espace l'espèce à partir de
scientifiques deuxième élément c'est que
nous travaillons au niveau national le
président d'ailleurs à cette occasion
avait rappelé le développement d'une
deuxième brigade de loup pour travailler
sur ces questions de prédation deuxième
élément travail au niveau national sur
quoi on peut travailler avec mon
collègue Christophe Béchu avec Bérengère
cougar nous travaillons sur ce sujet
dans le cadre du plan national loup ou à
l'extérieur de travailler sur des
modalités de simplification
simplification pour effectuer les
prélèvements réellement simplification
dans les procédures d'indemnisation trop
souvent l'indemnisation ne tient pas
compte de l'ensemble du préjudice qui
est porté on est que sur les animaux
prédatés mais pas ceux qui sont perdus
ou la perte génétique et ça c'est un
élément qui est important troisième
élément travailler sur un dénombrement
qui fasse l'objet d'un consensus puisque
c'est à partir de ce dénombrement que
les prélèvements sont effectués 19% de
la population recensée enfin dernier
élément il faut qu'on travaille aussi
sur le statut du Patou qui pose des tas
de questions juridiques pour les
éleveurs évidemment quand ils viennent
mordre ici ou là un touriste voilà
madame la sénatrice on est bien sur un
chemin que nous entendons tracer avec
mon collègue bechy et ma collègue
Couillard pour avancer parfaitement et
donner des moyens pour avancer pour
qu'on préserve l'agro pastoralisme on
doit aux éleveurs et on doit à la
biodiversité mais à toute la
biodiversité merci merci